Uh my name is Michael. Uh I work here at
Y Combinator. I help run the
accelerator. Uh before that I did two YC
startups. Um one in 2007 and one in
2012. And today I'm going to talk to you
about uh minimum viable product. So MVP
uh we always yell at founders to not use
jargon. Yet we have this whole set of
stupid startup jargon and MVP is one of
them. Um when you think about MVP you
should think about something
ridiculously simple. This is the first
thing you can give to the very first set
of users you want to target in order to
see if you can deliver any value at all
to them. That's all it is. It's
extremely simple.
Um I know you guys got a talk last week
about how to come up with ideas, how to
come up with problems you want to solve.
Um what I will tell you is that it is
helpful to talk to some users before you
decide to build your MVP. This doesn't
mean you have to go into a three-year
kind of research um situation or you
have to work in industry for 10 years.
Um but some conversations are helpful.
It's even more helpful if you're your
own user so you can tell whether your
product's working for you. Um I always
get this strange question of how do I
get my first users which always kind of
confuses me because theoretically you
decide to solve a problem that you know
someone has. So the way you get your
first user is you talk to that person
that you know has the problem. Um and if
it's you, it's even easier. So um if you
are building a product for a mysterious
set of users that you have no idea who
they are, question that slightly. Um
very slightly.
Okay. So the goal of a pre-launch
startup um is extremely simple. Step
one, launch quickly. This is something
that's been part of the YC ethos from
the very beginning and it's been great
advice for 10 years and it continues to
be great advice. Um, if you can walk
away from one thing from this
presentation, it's launch something bad
quickly. Um, that's it. Like literally
the rest of what I'm going to say is
basically going to be reummarized
versions of that same thing. The second
thing that an early stage startup needs
to do is get some initial customers. Get
anyone using your product. You don't
have to have a vision of how you get
everyone using it, but just anyone
interacting and seeing if they can get
value out of the product. You'd be
surprised at how many founders journeys
end before a single user has actually
interacted with a product they've
created. Um it's very very common. So
please get past this step. It's
extremely important. The next one is
talk to your users, any of them, after
you've launched this MVP and get
feedback. Um, this is one that's also
extremely common mistake because most
founders in their heads have a idea of
what they want to build. And so they
kind of have this weird feeling that if
I haven't built the full thing yet,
getting feedback on the shitty initial
thing is kind of useless. Of course,
it's not going to work. It's not the
full thing. the full thing is going to
take three years, $10 million, a whole
team. So feedback on the little thing is
useless. The reality is that
in some ways the full thing is this
really awesome idea in your head that
you should keep in your head, but it
should be very very flexible because it
might turn out the full thing that you
want to build isn't what your customers
want at all. So um kind of have this
saying, hold the problem you're solving
tightly, hold the customer tightly, hold
the solution you're building loosely.
And last, most important, iterate. And I
like to kind of distinguish between
iterating and pivoting. Um, a lot of
founders once they've figured out how to
build something fall in love with it.
And so if it doesn't work for a certain
set of users, they start thinking, well,
I wonder what other problems this thing
can solve. Well, you know, the
screwdriver is not actually good at
screwing in anything, but I wonder what
other problems it could solve. And
they're like, oh, maybe you can use it
to cook. Maybe you can use it to clean.
And it's like, no, like the problem was
I need to screw something in. The user
was like a mechanic. And if your
screwdriver doesn't help the mechanic
solve the problem, keep the mechanic.
Keep the problem. I need to screw
something in. Fix the
screwdriver. Like that's the thing
that's broken, right? The broken thing
is not the mechanic and it's not the
fact that they need to screw something
in. So iterate um continue improving on
your solution until it actually solves a
problem. In most cases, most people
should be building a very lean MVP. So,
by that we mean um you should be able to
build it fast in weeks, not months. Um
this can either involve software or
honestly we see startups just start with
a landing page and a spreadsheet. Um but
most startups can start very very fast.
Second, extremely limited functionality.
You need to condense down what your user
needs, what your initial user needs to a
very simple set of things. A lot of
times founders want to address all of
their users problems and all of their
potential users
when in reality they should just focus
on a small set of initial users and
their highest order problems and then
ignore the rest until later. Um you
should have a vision of everyone. You
should have an MVP very small. All this
is is a base to iterate from. That's it.
It's just a starting point. Um it
doesn't it's not special in any way. You
just have to start. And so please make
sure you don't feel like your MVP is too
special. Okay. Uh here is a classic
example. Uh this is one of Airbnb's
first landing pages uh in 2008
I believe. Um, one of the things that
you might be interested in about in
Airbnb's first product is that there
were no payments. When you found a place
to stay on Airbnb, you had to exchange
money with the host in person. Um,
needless to say, that was a pretty
big problem, but they started
without payments. No map view. You know
how when you search Airbnb, you can see
where the house is in the city? You
don't have that. Sorry. Um, and the
person writing all the code, Nate, was
working part-time. Okay, so everyone
tells these kind of magical stories
about how everything was perfect from
the beginning. Airbnb, not perfect from
the beginning. Uh, next one, Twitch.
This was what Twitch looked like day
one. Not very familiar. Well, maybe a
little familiar. There's some video
there and there's some chat there. Other
than that, nothing else. Uh, Twitch
launched as Justin TV, which was a
online reality TV show. There was only
one channel, Justin. You had to follow
his life. If you didn't like his life,
you had to leave the website. That's all
there was. Um, the video was extremely
low resolution. Um, it was funny. A
founder asked me back in the day like,
"Oh, like wasn't it weird you guys had
video in your apartment? Weren't there
all these like secret documents and
things that like people would be able to
see?" And it was like you could barely
recognize our faces, let alone documents
that we had. Um, and most importantly,
there were no video games. Uh, no video
games except if we decided to play video
games in our apartment. Like that was
the only time video games ever appeared.
Um, and so needless to say, you can do
that quickly when you think about
Twitch. It's much more complex now. Last
Stripe, which wasn't Stripe, it was
called slashdev/payments because why
not? Like, let's make a name that's
really easy to remember. Um, this was
Stripe day one. No bank deals. I won't
tell you exactly how they process
payments, but uh, it was in a very
startupy way. Um, almost no features and
even cooler, if you wanted to use
Stripe, the Stripe founders would come
to your office and integrate it for you.
How nice is that? Um, half because they
were just desperate to get anyone to use
it and half because it was a great way
to find bugs before the users found
bugs. uh integrate yourself. So these
are just three examples of extremely
simple, extremely fast to build MVPs. Um
all of these are billion-dollar
companies and they all started with
something that most people would say is
pretty shitty. In very few cases, you
have to build a heavy MVP.
I just invented that term heavy MVP when
I made this presentation two days ago.
So uh you know, maybe becomes a thing.
If you're in an industry with
significant regulation like insurance or
banking, um sometimes drones, although
sometimes not. Um it's hard to launch.
Uh it's it's harder to launch. You have
to pass through a bunch of regulatory
bodies first. If you're doing hard tech,
if you are building rockets, it is hard
to build a rocket in a couple weeks. Uh
biotech, it is hard to invent a cancer
drug in a couple weeks. Uh moonshots,
well, fill in all the other blanks. It's
hard to bore tunnels in the earth and
have extremely fast vehicles that
replace cars in a couple weeks. So, if
you're in that situation,
um please remember that your MVP can
start with a simple simple website that
explains what you do. Um it's helpful
when you talk to people, interact with
people that they can refer back to
something. So, that can be your start
and you can build that simple website in
days, not weeks. So many ways maybe your
M heavy MVPs are faster than your lean
MVPs in some weird strange way.
Now I want to talk about launching for a
second because a lot of founders have
this misconception about launching. Um
they see big companies launch stuff and
they assume that's what startups do. In
fact they see companies they kind of
think about like startups. you know,
Facebook's not really a startup anymore,
but they see them getting a lot of press
and getting a lot of buzz and yada yada
yada, and they have in their head that
that's what a successful company looks
like when they launch. Well, let me ask
you this question. Um, how many here
remember the day that Google launched?
No. How about Facebook?
Um, okay. How about Twitter? No. Great.
So, it turns out that launches aren't
that special at all. Okay. So, if you
have this magical idea of your magical
launch you want to do, throw it away.
It's not that special. Um, the number
one thing that's really important is to
get some customers. So, to make people
feel better, um, let's use different
terms. How about launch is when you get
any customers. And how about like press
launch? Press launch really impressive
is when like people write about things
and it's all exciting and you get all
this buzz. Let's push the press launch
off and let's push the get any customers
launch really really soon. Um, that's
our goal here.
It's a lot harder to learn from your
customers when they don't have a product
they can play with. You know, you can
talk to your customer all day, but you
have no idea whether the thing you want
to build can solve their problem. If you
put the thing in front of them and it
doesn't solve their problem, you know
right away. And so all the research in
the world is good, but until you can put
something in front of people, you have
no faking idea whether it's going to
work. So spending all that time on a
pitch deck is not as valuable as
spending your time building anything
that you can give to a customer.
Finally, some hacks for building an MVP
extremely quickly. First, time box your
spec. So your spec is a list of stuff
you need to build before you launch.
Time box it. say, "Okay, what happens if
I want to launch in three weeks?" Okay,
well, the only things that could be on
my spec are things I can build in three
weeks. That makes your life a lot
simpler. It allows you to remove all the
features you can't build in 3 weeks.
Second, write your spec. This seems
really straightforward, but most people
this one up. Um, it's really easy
to change what you're working on before
you ever launch it because you never
write it down. You start working on
something, you talk to a user, they say,
"Oh, I would never use that." Or, god
forbid, you talk to an investor and they
say, "Oh, that could never be a
company." Because investors know
everything. And so, you decide to change
what you're working on. And because you
never wrote it down, you don't even
really realize you're changing it. And
so, your three-week plan turns into a
three-month plan. If you write
down, at least you can be honest with
yourself that you're changing your spec
all the time.
The next one is cut your spec. A week
into your kind of three-week sprint, you
probably realize that you added too many
things to your spec and you're not going
to make your deadline. That's okay. Just
cut the stuff that clearly isn't
important. Um, and if there's no
non-important things, start cutting
important things. Um, most of the goal
here is just to get anything out in the
world. Once you get anything out in the
world, the momentum to keep anything
going is extremely strong. Once you have
any once if you don't have anything out
in the world, it's very easy to just
delay, delay, delay, delay. And then
last, don't fall in love with your MVP.
So many people fall in love with the
vision in their head. And none of the
products I showed you before was the
initial vision, what it ended up being.
So please don't fall in love with your
MVP. Um, it's just step one in a
journey. um you wouldn't fall in love
with a paper you wrote in the first
grade and like that's like the level of
impact often your MVP has. All right, it
was great talking to all of you. Thank
you very much.
[Applause]